the man whose negotiations with David
Cameron failed to avert the brexit vote
with a plan on negotiating its
consequences
EU Council President Donald Tusk
sounding like he's already playing
hardball Wow and on low health we have
achieved sufficient progress on the
withdrawal can we discuss the framework
for our future relationship starting
power talks on all issues at the same
time as suggested by some and the UK
will not happen but this was a softening
of the French German position that
withdrawal talks need to wrap up before
trade talks between Britain and the EU
begin one priority and tusk guidelines
is agreeing reciprocal guarantees of EU
and UK citizens another making sure a
non-member of the Union that doesn't
live up to the same obligations as a
member cannot have the same rights and
enjoy the same benefits as a member and
there can be no cherry-picking but also
in an apparent concession to the UK the
second phase of the negotiations can
begin as soon as sufficient progress has
been made in the first phase towards
reaching a satisfactory agreement so
what exactly does sufficient progress
mean I asked the Maltese prime minister
and current rotating EU President Joseph
Muscat first we agree on the principles
of the exit then once the principles of
the exit are agreed we'll start talking
about the future relationship but and
that's a very important but the
sufficient progress will be determined
by the 27 that sounds like a steak not a
carrot no I think it's about negotiating
its freedom day here when multi
celebrates the moment the last British
warship sailed out of its waters since
then the two countries have maintained
close ties after this brexit with
tortuous negotiations ahead can Britain
and the European Union do the same
on another rocky outcrop at the other
end of the Mediterranean tusk guidelines
a causing outrage they appear to offer
Spain of veto on the future of Gibraltar
infuriating the territory's Chief
Minister let's be very clear about what
Spain is doing she is employing her
unhealthy obsession with Gibraltar and
bring it to the table of a very complex
negotiation already Gibraltar is not
going to be a political born in brexit
neither is it going to be a victim of
brexit Gibraltar is going to be very
prosperous and very successful and
entirely British before during and after
grexit so if there is any suggestion
that gibraltars somehow in play then it
is absolutely erroneous just one thorny
issue among many likely to be devil
brett's it talks in the months and years
ahead
Dominic Waghorn Sky News in Malta